to weigh in on more of this breaking
news he will have a big part to play in
this in the united states senate
south carolina senator lindsey graham
senator
um i think we are beginning now the the
painting
the picture is beginning to fill in with
the corroboration
not that we needed it we haven't been
wrong here we've been way ahead of the
curve thanks to great reporting of the
people we have on this show tonight and
many many others that i mentioned
but these are questions now that your
committee will be dealing with
to get to the bottom of it take this
news and tell us what how you interpret
it
well this is the tip of the iceberg i
know personally there's a lot more out
there
and the word that keeps coming up is
bias the people
investigating clinton wanted her to win
and trump to lose
the people who started the investigation
against president trump
wanted him to lose and her to win the
chief source of
the fisa warrant was mr steele who hated
trump's guts
so there's a common theme here that the
the investigation
of trump was very biased and uh
the fact that mccabe is sued is very
interesting to me
it gives me a chance as the chairman of
the committee to look into whether or
not the fbi acted
inappropriately toward mr mccabe or was
it his
fault that he got fired i'll look into
that mr senator
is it fair for me to say the following
that all of this cast of characters
the majority of them were involved in a
rigged investigation where the evidence
into
violating the espionage act was
overwhelming incontrovertible
and that being the underlying crime the
subpoenaed emails that were deleted and
acid washed and beaten up with hammers
etc
that that would be a a slam dunk
obstruction case
is it fair to say that the russian lies
that hillary clinton bought and paid for
that even steele didn't stand by
was in fact used as the basis of a fisa
application
on four separate occasions one full year
denying the civil liberties of one card
or page and also
backdooring spying into the trump
campaign trump transition and later
trump presidency
and is it fair to say that it is looking
more likely every day
that top officials in our intelligence
community
abuse their power and to circumvent
american law
outsource things that would be illegal
for them to do
spying on americans and using spies
like joseph misford and stefan halper
and allied
allies of ours again to on a separate
track to against fire on the trump
transition trump presidency
is that is that a fair conclusion at
this point where we're going
yeah i think it's a pretty good overview
the question for me
is is the reason hillary clinton wasn't
prosecuted is because
they wanted her to be president if they
knew that
they knew that if they brought a case
against hillary clinton for compromising
classified information
she would lose the election and they
didn't want her to lose i think the
insurance policy is what we're seeing
here
getting into the trump campaign the fisa
warrant against carter page was a fraud
i believe
and the counterintelligence
investigation is something we need to
look
at really closely